um so when he pushes into me
you'll see there's some sort of
absorption that happens
okay so you you can
i go this way you see
contrast is no absorption i'm like a a
brick wall
do you see that okay that absorption
can happen externally you see i've moved
that externally
that absorption can happen a mixture of
of external
and internal so i didn't have to move as
back as far and that absorption can
can be just internal to okay and i'll
show you what you can do with these so
um
what am i absorbing to i'm absorbing to
the ground
vector and outside of his power arc
okay so he's going to push there's
there's the ground vector and if you
don't move your feet
and you try to push just hold there
there push hard there you see he reached
the limit of his push
what would be the difference i'm inside
his his
arc his arc power i'm in here you see
and we do we do the same thing and i go
push
and he's gonna he's gonna displace me
okay
um you can do the combination so that
means that inside i'm i'm relaxing and
this energy is going really to the
ground very quickly
and because of that i don't have to
make an another external movement back
so i do an
external movement outside his power arc
and then
i move into it and i get to project him
okay so i can do it
a mixture of the two and i can do it
with just
internal this way it's just same thing
okay
so you're doing this technique and a lot
of you are staying in the power arc
so he goes to he goes to grab and you're
here
and again he's there
and if he pushes he's still got a lot of
umph
okay so when you do your deviation it's
got to be outside of that power arc
he pushes up he's at it full
power you see
so i'm moving i'm out of it and
that's where i can come back okay
another way of looking at this is in
your yin and yang if you're inside this
power arc he's still on the yang face so
you can't go back in that would be a
yang young clash
okay so i move outside of that power
and then back in outside of the power
arc
on the map outside
outside
so if you're inside the power arc let's
get to the question now what are you
adhering on
well if you're inside the power arc
you're not going to be adhering on
anything
because you're going to go young to yang
okay
and for the ik adhesion you have to be
at
that neutral that zero pressure i'm not
positive young i'm not negative again
okay so i gotta get to this part where
there's nothing left
and that's what i adhere to once you
adhere to
whatever you touch so i
touch here and i touch here and that's
what i adhere to
you bring it more external and you're
going to see i'm going to do less
movement meaning i am inside what
appears to be his
external power arc but because i'm
internally reconciling his energy he's
not really pushing on me
okay so this would be a big movement you
see
now you can do the same thing with small
movements
then desean's question
bring them around if you ghost
if you lust for the immediate down
you're actually behind
and he goes won't bring him
around and he is already
actual hip so when you come up
you'll have the trap already
this is also going to condition you
better
as it creates lateral towards your body
this is no
torque in your body i gotta hold my
structure
and bring him around
leave the last step up
not gonna move his arm like that i know
it kind of looks like that
okay but when i step up
i'm gonna make another curve this way so
i
went like this and now i'm going to go
like this
and when i do that i'm going to get on
the inside of his elbow
not the back and not the top i'll go
slow and
you'll tap out when you when you don't
like
see how i'm here on the
inside of his though not
not moving around like this
i'm going to get on the inside right
here
okay then
here inside
you want to be able to snap
so go slow be responsive
and then not gonna be responsive let go
okay so uh i think it's gonna get
tighter
it's all gonna get tighter on his body
it's not here
it was tight as he came around and then
he got loose
it's loose and then it got tight
when you're applying these spirals
it's going to get like tight so i
haven't moved yet
and you'll tap when you don't like it
you see
you shouldn't even get to the last to
the end of the move
okay it's very much like side control
right if i have everything in place
you'll you won't see the the movement of
the technique you see
i don't have to have this big movement
i'm doing it wrong
or wrong
it's going to get tight i can't get to
the
full stance so if you want to get to the
full stance
you're going to have to release it a
little and you'll never get there
okay but it shouldn't be all off
and then he's moving around on you
these changes or these continuations of
that figure eight pattern
gets things tighter not tied
loose tied loose tight loose
it's not like that okay so
we're gonna work on getting onto the
inside what a spiral allows me to do
is i don't have to work on the xy so
although
i'm on this side of this body because
i'm
i'm i'm actually on the inside of his
arm i can go around to the other side
you boom boom
[Music]
and i'm going to go around this arm to
the other side i'm already on the other
side
bring the arm and you'll sit i'm sitting
on this other arm
i'm already on the other side of his
body past the head mount
here
his other arm is trapped under my kiza
already on the other side use your whole
body
not just your arm use your whole body
head mouth either side
around his arm he's on his other arm
go slow and control
often when we come to the art we can't
see the spiral
we see curves we see circles we see two
dimensionals because they're just
there's still plots on the x y axis and
the spiral belongs to the void in our
our ego tripartite or conscious mind
really can't see that if we lose track
of the spiral if you've ever stared in a
spiral
and after a while you're like wait is it
going forward is it going backwards
where's the end all that kind of it gets
it and that's kind of what's happening
in this technique is you guys so you
kind of like it's two-dimensional down
down and you're trying to oh
all right okay you're trying to go like
that
and then it gets loose okay so instead
it should get tighter so it's gonna it's
gonna get tighter
as i'm going around it so i won't loosen
it as i go and you're gonna see
he'll tap when you want to see so i
gotta loosen it and i'm going around it
it's on this side of me but i'm gonna go
around it
to the other side of it and then around
it
one more time so it's back in front of
me
i'm on this side i'm going to get to the
other side the other side of it
and then i'm going to get back on the
other side of it back on the other side
not here back on the other side of it
so it stays in front of me
that's why it's a good drill okay just
loosen it up as your
uk shoulder needs to so you can practice
working this spiral okay